哈喽各位同学大家晚安
哈喽哈喽看得到我吗
今天的课程是这个
舍不得赔就舍不得赚
等一下我们可以好好的来聊一下
好不好
我们先来回答一些同学的一些问题
前面有同学说要去听沈玉玲的讲座
下次带他一起到家里看老鱼直播
这开车开得很厉害
我是煮牛肉面的那一款
还是别人煮给你吃的那一款
我
第一个我吃素
基本上我跟我老婆就随意了
两个都可以
我回答一些问题
同学问说股票除全息
除全后跟那个还原的图是不一样的
那以哪一张图为准
我都不去按那个除全后的图
我都用原来的图
为什么会这样讲
因为我这样就可以知道说
眼前这个价格就算扣掉了那个利息
扣掉了那个价格
我一样知道说市场这些人对于这个价格
他的反应是如何
如果要他持有到明年他愿意吗
我可以看眼前他这个价格的样子
所以我都是用原图在做这样
那我今天的小娜我也有做
就是看起来准备要回来
我在这边吃一次这边吃一次
这两次其实我自己都知道
不是并不是适合我的点
但是就是刚好看到
好 摸一下摸一下
就摸了两下
失败以后发现是好像不太对
所以今天其实没有什么碰
那我不太对的想法其实很简单
就是他的60k是整个这样下来的
你自己等一下自己去看一下
那我先看一下旁边
我同学说圣诞树一路赔到底
如果是这样子
我觉得你要问自己一下
你可以在你自己的这个交易的图里面
例如说你是打破底翻
或是你是打互换
这样子
那你可以这样子把这个图用半透明的例如说你打哪里假设你打在这边或这个附近这里看起来有点东西
有点像,可以给过
有像的打勾
不像的,例如说我这张
我的这张单子就是要打屁股的单子
我怎么样对,你看对齐在这边
我怎么对都对不出标准图
这个就是摆明乱摸的单
打X
你就自己比对一下你今天假设出手了10次
这10次到底是几次是这样子的标准图
几次是乱七八糟像我刚刚这个这样子乱摸
你可以自己回来评估一下
如果他全部都长一个样子
理论上你应该不至于到出手很多次一直赔很多
如果你是很多都没有跟这个样子一样
刚刚两个标准图
自己去比对
今天看起来没有互换的机会
我再猜可能只有破第一番
如果你比对发现
有一半以上都不是标准动作的单子
那你要回去检讨的不是图的问题
你要检讨的是
你为什么没有设定
同学说的对
第一个你为什么没有设定
我今天亏多少钱就收手的这个机制
这是第一点
第二点
你为什么没有设定
我今天出手要多少次有标准图的这样子
你需要做到这件事情
所以问题可能
例如说最标准的标准图也杀破了
这位同学来
最标准的标准图
不代表他一定会涨或一定会跌
甚至也不代表他上涨或下跌的几率的高低
我只能说这个很标准我认得他
但是我认得他是一回事
他会不会赚会不会赔那又是另外一回事
而我们的标准图的确是在提高胜率用的
但如果他今天是一个一路往下走的图
任何图你用均线也好
用任何一个指标也好
全部都会破啊
因为他今天就是大刻度往下走啊
大家可以理解我这样子的想法吗
所以给这位Leo同学因为我不知道你的图长什么样如果你是摸摸摸摸摸各种赔
例如说你打出来的图是像这样子
好多亏损的这种店
那问题应该不在于坛面本身
在于你的刹车坏掉
你可以赔钱赔钱是正常的
但是但是刹车坏掉了
那我们就要在下一次
你重新进入这个交易的时候
可能是明天可能是后天
然后再额外的用白纸黑字写在旁边
说我有什么样子的煞车
出现什么情形我就要踩煞车不要做
而不是等到圣诞书打完了才煞车
这样好不好
那我这边可以很明确的跟大家讲
眼前的行情换边了
这个这个动作我看好久了
那你说老鱼这边是不是也一次
对啊
这个点跟这个点好像有没有觉得
出现这个以后等他回来再吃
好所以出现这个以后怎么样
对你不用急
等这个力量是开始变成上楼梯的再说
这样好不好
1K吃再
你怎么可以趁我很认真在讲话的时候
1K
1K这个点
这个点,这里这里这里
Peter,可恶
可恶
然后刚刚有个同学
80.11,80.15,这个我要聊一下
我觉得这个有必要讨论一下
好,我没吃到底下就算了
Peter,赞哦!就是这种边界
不是你哦?
是另外一位同学
那位同学这个你吃了87对87在这里
如果是这样在1K来讲这是好的
好的边界二一个点两个点破尖尖的隔壁
这个是教科书等级的一模一样的东西
我们来看一下原油原油原油刚好同学吃原油
原油
5K在1比10的位置出了
好我看一下你的5K在干嘛呢
好你说80.15 80
哪里?84吧是不是你是还是我们两个下的原油是不同的月份的合约你要告诉我一下你的合约是哪一个月份的那我从图形上我看
我在猜你可能是吃这边吧
对那因为我不确定你用的交易所是哪里
如果你是吃这边
那怎么说就是区间上缘
目前是这样子
还是你是吃80
真的是80
在这前面
应该没有这么远
等你说一下
我先来讲解别的东西
下午3点多小纳15k
3点多
你讲的是不是这个
这个是2点多
还是你讲的是这边
来
如果你说的是这里
如果你说的是这边
那我们就回到当下
这是一个很好的案例
来来来
各位都知道
我们在做交易
我们要等到这边
回来的时候
来到这里
我需要出现什么
关心要干嘛
要停下来
我要出现停下来的
打脚的这种
这种底下拉上来
底下拉上来
对吧
我要出现这个
这个我才能够断定说
这个边界有人用
如果是很凶的下来
像这种像这样子的K棒
很凶的在这种地方下来
这是不值得吃的哦
所以来到这个地方
假设你画了一条线
我不管你标在哪里
反正这个地方
来我们看一下最新的这一根
有没有凶
这是一根几乎满满从头杀到尾的K棒
对吧
好那下一根呢
下一根呢
有吗
没有
所以你就知道
这两根都长这样子
请问要不要下单
而且你看到的是这个边界
应该撑住的地方对过来
哇
变成是长下影线下来
所以下午三点多这里
看到这一根就知道
下15分钟不能下单
看到这根又知道
下15分钟又不能下单
好再来再来
看到这根就知道
下15分钟不能下单
我就继续哦
我讲一样的事情哦
看到这根就知道
下15分钟不能下单
下15分钟
诶
对不起多了
这根的隔壁
哎呦有抽这个
好吧
隔壁的15分k你要摸一下
如果是在这边我可能会给过
但是这个很极限的摸
他单纯就只是在摸这个边界而已
也还不是纯15分k该有的标准图
好不好
给这位Semi同学
如果你是在5K
刚刚有同学说是那个5K
5K在哪里
应该是
你讲的是这里对不对
如果你是在5k
你摸在这边
860这里我会给过可以
因为他再怎么样出现停顿的这个
你就照着摸吧
只是摸以后一下子就摸失败了
那就这样子
反正你的失败也了不起就这样
你不会亏到
你不会亏一个大的亏这样子
对吧你顶多就这样子而已
其实还好
这样可以吗?好不好?
有东西问现在什么东西
小稻穷现在60K有符合
小稻穷在哪里?符合三问吗?小稻穷
我查一下小稻穷
我直接叫我这里叫好了
叫YM
60K
哦其實60K還不錯
我看一下但是但是
不用急哦
小道比小娜好漂亮好多哦
小道的60K
有停下來小娜才正
正要開始也還沒
我看一下日線哦
日線的小道窮比小娜漂亮很多
又是回到這裡來
那今天如果是這樣子
其實你明天再下單都不遲
我们回到60k
如果这个是尖尖的
尖尖的左边有这个宽度
代表右边如果也整理出这样子的宽度
假设今天晚上在这边
各种涨叠
打出了左右大约等距离的宽度
时间宽度
那这个地方就很容易上去
好不好这样子
ok
那有同學說學同一道方法很多停損的標準圖
如果是這樣子其實
兩三次標準圖一兩次二次二我覺得這樣OK代表今天就是一個不屬於我们交易法的一天如果你能够在不属于我们交易法的一天
你可以用小培出场
你有亏损都没有关系
那哪一天轮到市场是我们交易法的一天的时候
站在我们身上的时候
那是不是就换我们吃香喝辣的了
这样啊
好不好那就是
就是这样
所以小稻穷整体而言
我觉得比小娜好做
这样看起来
不过现在我之所以说
现在没有到很想吃进去
因为纯小食可以来看
上面这几个上影线有点讨厌
所以我会看到这边
就有点夹心饼干夹在中间
好不好
那
我们来我同学都要问现在几时行情
我们先回答一下
30k
这个30k有点尴尬你知道吗
因为你看他左边这根的最低价
这个的最低价跟这个几乎是同一个价格
所以现在眼前的小纳我会用这样子看
因为底下有一个点
这里有两个点啊
所以如果刚刚左边这边
它没有这么低
它是在这里
在这附近跟这个差不多高
这样我都会接受这附近的单子
现在这附近的单子
嗯
存30k哦
你看因为这边又有这个墙壁在这边
我很难去
去评估好坏
你知道我的意思吗
再回来30k的一下
他有这个点跟这个点
所以我不会
我不会单纯拿这个尖尖的就拿来吃
这样子
就没有很好判断
这样
好那我先来开始慢慢进入今天的政客
其实今天有蛮多时间要跟大家聊天的
所以大家不用急
好不好
那今天的主题其实是要聊到这个
舍不得赚舍不得赔的这件事情
那是因为前一段时间
其实我看到很多网友都看人家在赚钱然后自己都空手不知道怎么做等到他最後衝進去的時候居然是直接要殺下來的時候
就我們來想一下
他們為什麼前面都捨不得
最後非常捨得
這樣
OK
來
那我們先回答一些問題
還有我剛剛也看到一些問題
就全部拉過來
這是不同人的問題
第一個從這個
這個講一下
這是有一位同學他說他看到我在DVBS那邊的直播
我說華新科不錯當時啦
然後同學說哇是漂亮的破底翻買了幾股成本幾張吧
成本265
今天311了
我們先來看一下這個我剛好叫出來
不是忘開了華新科
好像抓2492對不對
對對對華新科
先把這個拉到旁邊
同学说他吃在哪里
哦有我知道
我相信我那天去
我应该是看到这个东西
就是这个东西
这些下影线这样子
很好啊
所以你大概是吃在这附近
然后你跟我传讯息
给我说大概在这附近
今天回来
那就看你现在的交易计划了
你的计划是
回来这附近
如果有长下影线
继续加部位也可以
或是你要直接守成本也可以
或是說你要回來這邊成本也沒有關係
你防守仍然在下面
回來繼續接
那這個就代表如果再繼續疊
你是真的會賠錢的
所以目前看起來是這樣
只是這邊這個互換我不太會做而已
好不好
所以這個標準圖不錯
然後再來
我來回答這個問題一下
先回答上面這個
同學說考試都能考過但無法撐到出經
出經前永遠都是靜香情卻
一直怕獲利回途
這個本質上跟今天的主題都會有
會講到
我們等一下後面再來聊
好吧
那我們先來回答這個
常說878往下走
但破底翻最後那個斜解的
如何判斷87是真的
是878下來
他講的是這樣子
破底翻的這一段
这段他怎么样也都是斜斜的下来
对不对
所以如何判断是斜斜很凶的往下
还是破底翻的斜
毕竟破底翻的图最后斜斜的势必会往下好来我们用眼前的小娜来当一个讲解
来我刚刚有没有说我刚是不是讲说这里怎么样
这里不好对不对
那我们就用这个位置来聊一下
不对我刚刚是用刚刚我们在讲解那个五分K的破底翻的这里
来来来
假设你是在做五分K的破底翻
这边下来的地方
这里
这的确是斜斜的对吧
但是注意看哦
但是这个斜斜的在关键的框框
大概在这个区域
这个区域也是对到这些地方
它出现了这个
如果我有看盘我会下单
它出现了一个关键的停顿的动作
而且这个停顿它有把短线的一些边界给杀破
所以这个小边界有破了再回来
哦
你知道这种感觉吗
小边界震荡震荡震荡
咔拉回来
哎呦
应该一路往下杀却没有杀
所以我会在这边等待
注意惯性停住
我的说法里面我会说
那个叫原地停顿
这样
OK
所以你在做交易的时候
在这里
这个地方行情这么凶的过来
我刚不是说吗
很凶的大K棒下来的时候要干嘛
要干嘛
要闪一边对不对
那不值得下单
如果是这种
如果是这里
注意看我话
行情从这边注意看
K棒带着长上影线
隔壁的K棒长这样子
实体K棒不大
也是上影线
这边也是这样子
這邊一個這樣子
還是上影線來
請問
在這種情形下各種上影線回到這個邊界
也都沒有長角
我要不要理他
NO
所以不單純只是看
看最後一根不是
我要看他一路過來的那個樣子
他是怎麼過來的
那我畫一個我喜歡的好不好
我喜歡的是這樣子
我們就從這邊往下畫好不好
我喜歡的是上面這邊一樣長上影線
這個OK
這樣
这个边界这样子
但是我希望这边来一个直接来一根或两根用力的杀
我要这个比较大的满满用力的K棒在中间
中间段那我是不是就可以把这个小亚当给翻下来
哦那如果是这样子翻下来我是不是可以很清楚的去这个底下这里等待什么
等待市场可能再杀一次
再杀一次
然後在這個地方再殺一次殺一次殺不下去了
變成變成尖尖的在這裡
喔 對吧
我喜歡的是這樣中間很兇
兩個端點最上面的端點跟最下面的端點
都是小K棒並且長著向下面要長下影線
我今天把我在判斷的邏輯很明確的
这样照顺序的讲过来
是这个是不要的
这个是要的
虽然图有点丑
但是我相信大家知道我在讲什么
对吧
这样OK吗
所以有关于这个
我应该算讲解完了
所以最后的那个决定的关键
就是停顿了没
那我们用眼前的K棒来带大家看一下
好来来来
假裝你要下單 我現在沒有真的要下單 因為這60K很醜 我只是要等而已
假裝我們要下單 請問目前這樣子 長上影線跟這樣子 值得下單嗎?
值得下單嗎?
喔 對吧 有邊界啊 不值得 為什麼 我光看這邊就知道 來 很兇 等
吃嘛 等
一堆上影線 斜斜的 一堆上影線 幹嘛? 等
那什么时候值得下单
如果以这张图
最好是把这个边界给打下去
如果有一个K棒是这样子
借我用一下
如果他等一下是有一个5分K是这样子
很用力的
很用力的像这样
不对
用错了再一次
很用力的往下杀这样
这里杀破
杀破的瞬间然后底下出现成交量
底下成交量都都都都都哇
长出来
结果K棒开始长角就是这个开始长长角长角长角最后变成这样子变成这样子在这里边界都破了 出现这个
哦 那如果这个动作发生在我刚刚讲的
破底翻的这里
这个动作发生在这个地方
好不好
如果是这样子的
哦 那我们该要等待的东西都有啦
那你就可以等市场怎么样
你看要下去了
所以我刚刚是不是跟你说底下这个边界怎么样不够漂亮
有没有
这样看得出来了吗
那我刚刚有没有很直觉的告诉大家
我这边一看到就觉得
这K棒的力量是往哪里走
所以假设在盘中
在这一根
我看到这一根
你觉得这个边界要不要乱摸
不要
这个边界一看长上影线
空方力量有这么大
做多的力量
只有一点点
这个城墙很快就破掉了
好吗
所以我现在看来
我讲的东西都会发生
我就说了以后各位在网路上面
不要跟我
做对我就诅咒你的股票
好
那
那我們就繼續囉 好不好
很多屬於上禮拜看我停損好幾次
怎麼決定要賠
通常是這樣子
如果我有大顆度撐腰
我當天會勇敢一點
如果我沒有大顆度撐腰
我當天會縮手會懦弱一點
比較不敢打一點
這樣所謂的大顆度是指什麼
來
我直接切60
请问眼前的60k
有任何
有任何整理以后上楼梯的样子吗
假设明天的60k展开这里
这边的60k我会更愿意打单
但是眼前我看到的60k就是这样子
所以这也是触发了我不想要继续吃的原因
我觉得目前眼前都不对
所以这个60k要码是把它打破
打一个60分k等级的很用力的这种
这里这样子的隔壁这里我会下单或是干脆两条线往上走上去回来的这里这里我也会下单这两个点,而这两个点对我来讲
都是我的军队跟我站在同一边
但是目前我看起来
做多的人
没有人权,一点没有援军要来救他
这样啊
好不好
那我一定注意哦
我要在我眼前
你说要对照鱿鱼
那你从这边看
哇这边看是做多
没有呢
这边的力量早就在这边的过程中
他就用掉了
如果市场做多还有力
他连在这边都不会回来
这边就会继续走
如果做多还有力
他就不会回到这个地方来了
太久了不用不用
我们要看的是当下
当下
那你可以抓这样子说
例如说前面
例如说这里有一大坨
所以假设哪一天跌回来这个地方
你可以观察说
市场有没有在同样的框框里面
产生化学反应
他有没有在这边有人买
有人买
你可以在这里观察
但是你不能直接就当作这边会是有效的
这样
好不好
60K亞當滿足區啊
所以我覺得最近很值得觀察邊界
他剛變成盤整而已
這邊是滿足區沒錯啊
好
大家一直問問題我今天課程到現在都還沒講到
我再回答一個問題一下好不好
剛剛有人空原油84.5
5分K嗎你要讓我知道一下你是做幾分K
因为如果你有让我知道你是做几分K
这样我比较好去做
84.5
84.50
这里吗
我抓这个边界对不对
我看一下你是做几分K
来
如果你是做1K
这里吗
你是做1K的这里吗
坦白讲我觉得你空的这个点
上面平平的在做空的時候
這是5分K的
上面平平的
底下斜斜的就算你做空以前就算是这样子出现这个长上隐线
我会犹豫的点是什么你知道吗
是你做空的这个位置
其实不是最边界
因为你看这个点
这个点
这个人
其实8455这里其实蛮多人来碰的对吧
对啊
所以如果你在做空
你是做空在8450这里
你在做空的当下其实蛮摸的
你心里要有底
这个单子
你如果我是你
我现在就会
就会直接
直接把这个
不赔
把风险拿掉
用不赔来跟他换
好不好
因为眼前的这个样子
主要是我看到是上面这个边界
一直被碰
如果他这边比较干净一点
甚至都压在这种边界
只有一个人这样戳出来
那这个的优势就好很多
但是他好多个上来
这个有点讨厌
出书的时间
来
我如果可以在8月20号以前
把我完整的稿
包含我说把图片编好的稿
给苏昌
他说11月就可以出了
苏昌今天跟我说的
这样子
所以我要拼命的
有啦
其实我现在在看那些图片
其实好
也要注意哦
原有这个
我说我现在看图片
把图片编号
已经开始进入
那个
那个我的步调里面
大概在一两天
应该差不多就可以搞定
因为其实文字都写的差不多
好
来先回来讲今天的事情
在这边
来我们先来聊一下
舍不得的这个想法
我这边写的其实很简单
用了生存所需的金钱
所以你会很在乎这个亏损
然后你没有亏掉的勇气跟那个本钱
注意听我讲几个东西
例如说
来
老于老于
你这边不是有凹单吗
我跟你说
我所有的这些钱里面全部的钱赔掉
都不是我生存所需的钱
甚至这边连本金都已经是多的
所以我那时候在丢的时候就是眼睛闭着
水水便丢
因为光本金本身就已经是多的
我最早的本金什么那些早就都全部都回来了
所以这些钱对我来讲
来是生存需要的钱吗
不是
但是很多人
他说有有老爷我有准备钱
我去跟银行贷款用房子贷款也好
或是信贷也好
几百万进来
帶進來的錢你跟我說沒有壓力嗎?真的嗎?
漲的時候都沒有壓力,好爽喔
跌個幾天就像最近跌個幾天壓力就來了不是嗎?
如果你不小心買到的股票是跌停的
或是你跑去買的那個0050剛好買在最上面這幾天這樣下跌
跌個10%跌個20%
你心裡面不會緊張嗎?
人都會吧
尤其是借來的錢
那有一種人他借錢不緊張
他手上有三千萬 他跑去借一千萬
他不會緊張
但是我所知道很多人是
他手上銀行的流動資金可能只有二十萬
拿來過生活用
然後跑去跟銀行借了三五百萬
拿房貸去壓多少這樣子
就是他手上的現金只有一點點
那你覺得他會不會很害怕
例如说500万产生10%的亏损50万
会不会怕
他户头里都没有50万
结果股票亏个50万
会不会怕
会
你懂那种感觉吗
所以这也是为什么我一直跟大家强调
你不应该在交易的初期
就奢望可以用交易把
把你的负债给抹除
把你的房贷给缴清
把你的爸爸妈妈
让他们可以退休
把他们送出国玩
就是不要奢望这件事
好不好
来
不是生存所需的钱
等一下
这个我等一下会继续聊
不是生存所需的钱
也会怕
对不对
合理
那你就要回头思考一下
你这个怕到底是怕
是因为你没有一个固定的交易法
所以你会
你的心会有点飘
就算它不是你生存所需的钱因为你一下子这样子交易一下子摸摸单像我自己啦我举我自己当当例子好了
当我用了一个比较不一样的交易法
例如说我是贪平的
就算弹回去我心里面都觉得很不安很不安定
那这个单子我会很犹豫要报还是不要报要走还是不要走
因为这个交易法不是我所熟悉的交易法
不是我可以很轻松停损的东西
这是第一个
第二个
如果你用的不是
不是你
也不是生存所需的钱
我举个例子
我这边先把这个拿开
假设
你的都不会影响生活
你就丢了一个闲钱
闲钱500万
进入市场
你还是会考
在乎500万吧
对不对
那如果你下了一个比较大的部位
例如说你一只股票就直接吃满500万
一只股票全部重压在单一个个股
那你的心会不会跟它连接度非常的高
我会啊
因为你能够交易的所有的钱
全部都都在一只股票上
涨好爽
但是跌也好痛
哇
那就代表你下的部位太大了
所以我通常会建议
如果你是在一开始
你拨了500万进去某一个股票的户头里面
你不要动到全部的钱
怎么样都不要把全部的钱加进去
例如说你有500对不对
你就规定自己
我最一开始建仓
一开始建仓
了不起可能150到200之间
然后建立基本部位
你可能可以分三支股票
四支股票
五支股票都可以
一支30万
你可以吃五支股票
150万
对吧
你就分配一下一支30万
好
那后面的钱是什么样子
后面这些钱是
你前面这30万的股票赚钱了
赚钱了以后
用正向的方式来加码
上去回来还在挣的
你再把后面这些后备资金拿来加
加在不會倒賠的股票
這樣懂我這個想法嗎?你先試水溫,試對慢慢加或是說剛好在你的成本附近加了亏损也不大这些都可以承受的 先用这种角度
你不能一次第一笔交易就直接就进去
那你说可不可以摊平?
摊平就很麻烦
例如说前一段时间 7月底不是跌下去吗?
你有摊平的上来都赚对不对
但是我跟你说会习惯摊平的人
來我們看一下台子期
就用滑星科就好了
習慣攤平的人
他說如果我攤平在200塊這邊
我現在談起來280就賺了
有習慣攤平的人
他不會等到這裡才攤平
他稍微下來
他在這裡就在攤平了
然後這裡又攤平
這裡又大大大大的攤平
然後就下來了
這些成交量
就是這些攤平的人
大量的買的成交量
懂嗎?所以當你養成貪品習慣的人
他稍微回來就在貪,稍微回來就在貪
這很好笑
他根本熬不到最後面
如果你剛好遇到一隻股票
或是你遇到的市場剛好長這樣子
哇!
很慘
所以我其實會建議是
初始部位
初始部位不要大小小的
讓他小到你可以很輕鬆的去
砍!砍!OK!砍!
你可以很輕鬆的去做這種決策的時候
連續砍三次不會痛
好!這樣子代表那個部位很適合你
所以你每一次下單的時候你都要先想
如果我連續砍三次都是這種小部位
我會不會痛?
我會痛!代表部位太大!縮
縮了一半連續砍三次好像還好
好!那這個部位大小就可以
好不好 你說有沒有可能連續錯三次
有啊 這是很正常的事情啊
但是我錯三次不會怎麼樣 因為我部位不大
你說老魚 那我為什麼一定要用小部位 那個旁邊我強者我同學
大部位尻進去 直接去借房貸借了兩千萬出來
然後重壓現在翻四千了 早知道我就重壓了
我跟你說 你看到的就一個
你没看到躺在地板上的死掉的
有这么多个
但是银行不会跟你说
银行只会叫你一直借券商也不会跟你讲對吧我們在券商內部我們看太多太多太多了
然後這個動作每年
就是每一支股災他就是一直重複
長上去的時候各種少年股神
你的threats上面永遠都是各種
投資的東西
哇誰賺錢誰賺錢
美光賺錢
Sandisk賺錢
各種賺錢
你看到最近有沒有人貼啊
沒有了吧對不對為什麼
那些都不見了啊
對吧
所以就
就是我請我們家小朋友去看那個
那個GameStop的故事有沒有
就是那樣子
當初買在GameStop最上面的那些人
然後捨不得走的那些
一直怪東怪西的人到現在在哭
插鞋筒
他開了公司以後對又回去插鞋
公司现在暂时顶让给别人
来
那刚刚讲舍不得赔
那为什么会连赚都舍不得
第一个
会舍不得赚的人他
也没有交易计划
所以舍不得赔跟舍不得赚的人
通常是
他进场也不知道自己到底为何而进场
出场更不用说他也不知道什么情况下是适合他的出场
所以一下子又怕噴出少賺
又怕然後甚至有些人會是他知道說他的技術沒有很好
他也常常停損
好不容易咬到一單
然後希望這一單可以一單就直接把所有的虧損給補回來
我昨天虧10萬
今天吃一單賺了3萬不走
他就是想要一單直接把10萬最好變20萬
連本代曆的賺回來
所以他不觉得自己以后还可以做得到一样的交易
但如果像你像我们一样有标准动作
今天错过这一单就错过啊
或是我就照着我的计划做嘛
那我出场了
然后走掉以后后面继续喷他的事情
反正我明天可能又还有标准图可以做
后天一样还有
大后天还有
所以变成
我就不用
有那个压力说我这一只股票或这个期货
我就一定要幹嘛
是吧
然後還有另外一種
通常你會沒有交易計劃
或是你怕下一次吃不到這種賺錢單的人
你的腦袋裡面
滿滿都是金錢
那人性上面
當你的腦袋塞滿了金錢的時候
你會做一個動作
你會很害怕他失去
所以你會把它抱得緊緊的
緊緊的超級緊
所以你抱得越緊
你越捨不得獲利一點點的回吐
那麼一點回吐都很討厭
然後你就會開始從大顆度的K棒看到
例如說你會看到
我們剛剛是不是講原油
我是不是叫你拉一個不賠
哦對不對
然後小娜哦對不對對不對
我是不是說要破
你們別的說你有聽嗎
有沒有來
賺一點點就開始想著錢
所以你可能本來是看15分K下單
每15分鐘才跳一根
所以其實很慢
但是你會開始看5分K
又急著看1分K 然後去看1分這樣跳動
甚至有同學看到30秒K 15秒K
我還看過Tick圖在下單
你知道它的圖在每盤開盤時間 是...
是啪啪啪啪啪啪啪啪啪啪 這樣就是這樣
全螢幕的在晃動
然後你仔細看一下那個跳動
怎麼才5點10點就已經是它的全螢幕了
它縮得非常非常的細
不要啦好不好
我台子以前都要用EK
对我台子最早最早我的确是EK
但是我后来发现
EK我交给同学们的时候
哇塞那个得到的负评好高
但是EFK本身它就是杂讯很多的东西
就是他很短很靈敏
但是他太靈敏了
所以你會被掃到迷迷茂茂
对啊
所以后来才会发现也不行
做1K真的不需要
我退一步
5K 15K慢慢做
反而可以很轻松
然后看着1K的那些小朋友在那里
少来少去
给你玩给你玩
我等他整个掃完了
行情稳定一些有15分K的人跟我站在同一陣線好我再來做這樣都不遲破了下不去9點28
只要這邊有能力
上去回來了這裡漲漲的在這附近
這些都是點
只是這個點我讓5分K目測
可能我們準備就要下課了
好不好
來
承担风险的多寡是相对的
所以我刚刚是不是讲说
你不要去把你全部的资金都拿去承担风险
如果你是站在正向的角度去加部位
你会有增加风险吗
我画一个图给大家
假设我在这边有一个部位
这里有一个
行情来到这边
这里我加一
我有两个部位
但是我的防守守在这两个部位的均价防守在这里
请问打下来我会有额外的风险吗
不会打下来我是零风险
但是涨上去我有一个部位赚两个部位赚
涨的时候是两倍的赚
跌的时候风险是无风险
那我是不是很棒
对吧
不要乱吃哦
今天的这个波动很快哦
好不好
要做多的人来
现在你要做多的人
请你做一件事情
你画出一个这个5分K的这个图
然后呢
你就给他用个半透明
这样放着
对你就这样放着
好
这时候
你就乖乖的看直播
或者去做别的事情都好
去看沈玉鼎的讲座
都好
总之
你就这样放着
半透明的图放着
如果有类似这样子的图来
你才要出手
来问一下哦
如果我有用这个动作
各位下不去了
我会过度交易吗
不会啊
因为要符合这个样子的图还早了
还要有一根两根三根四根五根
可能要五根
五个五分k后大概就半个小时后
对吧
所以要符合还早了
你说老鱼那我刚刚如果直接摸
拜托
你连等个
等个60分可以出现这样子的
这个耐心都没有对不对我们就等假设行情真的要回到30,300这边肯定会有一些惯性改变的地方可能是这里可能是这里
我不知道
总之他一定会有机会让你上车
而且那个上车的点会比现在的单子还来得好做
你就等就好
等那个惯性站在你这边就好
好不好
那我说
没有适合的金额
没有适合每个人的金额
但是有适合每个人的相对的那个明确小风险的方法
例如假设刚刚是1K
这边连1K都没有
我们用这个好了
假设是这个
假设是这张单子的1K
你的防守只需要把这个边界给框进去
所以你可能吃这边
你的防守大概在这里
不到10点
也不用守到下影线的最下面
不需要
你光守这样就好了
这是很明确的动作
然后如果你是守
回来了
不要乱吃
像现在我吃在这个地方
我根本不知道怎么守
因为没有参考点
但如果这个1分K
注意哦
我切1K是因为
我们的讲课的时间就这么短
我只好这样子
例如說你剛剛吃在1K的這裡
你想說我防守當時的下影線在這邊就好了
結果同一根是不是一直跑
這一分K還有9秒鐘、8秒鐘才會停
是吧
那你看
這樣子
我根本要守哪裡我都不知道
破了吧
那如果
如果我有多等一下
假設這一根出現這樣子
5、4、3、2、1這裡還有50秒
停,這根要停,假設這根待會就停這樣子
一旦他停了以後下一根是不是會開始對吧
假設他停住是走十字線這樣子的
下一根會開始
一旦下一根開始以後前面這一根
這輩子往後一百年一千年
在2026年8月18週二下午9點33分的1分K
他的開高低收永遠不會變
他就寫死寫在這個系統上他不會浮動這個時候你的風險 假設你要做多 有這樣子慣性回來 破邊界慣性回來的這樣
風險也不大 吃665 防守可能645 好了不起把這個包進去20點給你
不要吃 這個我說不要吃 這個樣子不對
好不好 這也沒有停頓 我說是有停頓才要吃
各位有聽得懂我現在講的嗎
所以我為什麼下單前我一定要那個K棒停住的隔壁
你不要覺得我好像這個經驗好像很好玩一樣
我死了多少次才得到這個經驗
我在同一根K棒吃了打掉
然後當時也還沒破底又長下影線
又吃又打掉又吃又打掉
一個一分鐘我可以死三次
我死過這種
所以我才會得到一個結論
我太急了
不需要我要等K棒停住
那如果你是用5分K的勒
5分K的勒
這個5分鐘5分K還有3秒鐘2秒鐘停住
對你要像這樣子
你至少要等5分K停住
只是這5分K
波動好大
各位我先不管K棒的樣子
这个大波动并不是很适合多单来交易
波动越大空方越舒服
空方越喜欢
好不好
我宁愿等市场回去
这样子
但是你看哦
如果是这个5K
你真的要吃
你吃在这个地方
你的防守很简单
就是这里
有没有一个很明确的小风险的方法
有
就是这样
那如果你现在已经拉个不赔
你用赚赔比的角度来看
这边对
这边你在这里出场
1比上大概我眼睛目测
4还是5
1比4 1比5的赚赔
够你用的对不对
然后所以你吃一次赚的这个短单
你还可以有足够的金额
让你多停损两次
假设后面又有交易机会
多停损两次
还够用
对吗
我目前这样讲
应该有听到对不对
台子明天要结
台子礼拜三常常在结算
结算日
結算日如果你真的喜歡做短單
去注意結算日當天12點半開始的那個尾盤
尾盤去做選擇權應該會很有利
1分K等K棒停住
很好
停住的瞬間價格跑掉
例如說這個
停住的瞬間價格跑掉怎麼辦
4個字
就跑掉啊
你會打我 我跟你說
然後你在當下應該是很氣
啊 航行跑掉了
過一段時間 可能5分鐘 10分鐘
甚至大概半個小時後
你就會感謝你自己沒有很急著吃
像現在
像現在航行是不是慢慢回來了
剛剛那個1K不是在這裡嗎
對不對
這個人你覺得沒東西吃的
結果後面你看市場是不是又下來了
所以不需要去
你说你已经做到1分K了
我们的人生我们的交易生涯里面
难道连一分钟我们都等不到
都等不了吗
应该不会吧
我们应该是可以比较轻松一点的
这样子好
好我等你
对吧
我刚刚是不是有说
说你就把破底翻的图画在荧幕上面
然后等
所以剛剛的1K在這個地方
如果你在這附近施丹
好啦勉強給過
因為它其實有這個樣子
但是你現在要趕快拉個不賠
這動很快
黃金的邊界比較明顯
這倒是這個邊界
是說這個邊界的確很快就下來了
两条线要不要先在小10k
来我用这个先
我这边看到的是60分k在这个边界这里
这样子
我把其他的这个贴
我这个切一下ym好了
因为刚刚好像看到小道琼
小道琼这样也很凶
我看一下60分K
來
60分K原來的60分K我以為小到熊那裡很漂亮好不好美股開盤後我的新的60k上面一樣在這裡底下現在9點38還有20幾分鐘
如果待會20幾分鐘後停住
那我大概會畫這樣子的小10k
所以我就知道說好在這個邊界
我在5分k的這個邊界
在這附近我在等待我要的東西
可以這樣子是ok的
所以小小那的60k
我就比小道琼還醜
目前的60k
但是也是一樣下不去的樣子的
我的圖不是我這個圖是Tradify的
這樣子
但是也是PropFirm的其中一個沒錯
5k我看到的是這樣
這樣好不好
所以我們再拉回來
我剛剛講好防守很明確的點
他必須要K棒停住
這很重要哦
K棒要停住
所以你唯有等你要參考的這一根
停住了不要晃了
價格這輩子不會再變
你才拿他來當參考點
這樣才有意義
這時候你隔壁的射出來的那個邊界有沒有
他才不會浮動啊對吧
所以千萬不要在還在動的K棒當中
就直接拿這根K棒自己本身的低點或哪裡來當防守
這個沒有意義
這樣OK
昨天早上那一筆
哦哦哦昨天那筆來來來
我有叫出來對對對有同學問
同学问
这个单子吗
这个单子
我就抓这个边界
我就是这样摸而已
哪知道就摸对了
看一下放大
我就直接在这里摸
因为我看到了
来放大一点点
我看到这里有个下影线
我吃在这
当初我想说
防守
可以直接拉到这里也很近
好就给他吧
就这样
所以这是我当初的房子
也有可能当时就这样子打掉
就这样摸
只有边界二停损怎么设就像那样子
那我的脑袋里面其实
如果你对到更早出去你会看到这附近这些东西跟早上我撑了一整个早上你看从早上六点到中午这附近那我来讲一下有个习惯
市场有个习惯
如果早上在杀
亚洲盘早上在杀
常常那个停顿点
大概会是停顿在
有两个点
十点半或十一点半
十点半
我不确定到底是哪一个
但是常常在这里会停顿
为什么先讲11点半
因为中国的股市
他们的时间是11点半
所以如果是在11点半
他会有一个休息
他中午休息
然后就停止交易
起货还会动
现货是不动的
中国的股市
然后呢
所以他们11点半之前的这一段
很多人假设早上有赚到钱
就是说空方赚到钱
他想说
那就出一出中午去吃饭
所以10点半过后开始容易出现
下沙到某个程度开始慢慢反弹一些
那些空方上面下来的当冲的这些
他也不想熬过中午
他就早上这边准备尾盘的就直接出一出
这是我们很常见的这种
台湾也是早上有赚到钱的人
10点多11点了他们就出一出了
他也不管后面了
所以大成交量的时间点大概就是前面这一段
就是10點半之前
9點多10點多
大概就差不多
快到11點之後容易有那種轉折
這是我過去的經驗
這樣停損很大嗎
沒有這樣沒有很大
你看一下
這一條是180
我那個停損可能連10點
大概就10點而已吧
對啊
很小很小
那Stack方向出來了嗎
來
你要問的方向出來了嗎
這句話我覺得是陷阱題
對你自己來說的陷阱
什麼叫做方向出來了
這樣子你就會看得出來走多了
或是你叫著均線均線上來了
但是等你看到方向出來的時候
他就在這了
對吧
那我要如何事先知道
所以你要問的問題不應該問方向出來了嗎
應該要問的是問停住了嗎我知道前面一直在下殺我知道前面一直殺但這裡有沒有停住目前正在準備要停住當中
那我還是不會給你一個肯定的答案說
停住了沒停
我沒有辦法
我只能跟你講說眼前還在這邊晃
所以如果下一次行情咚咚咚咚咚
跑到這裡來
這附近鬼混鬼混鬼混
然後出現各種下雨線在這個地方
如果出現這樣子
我還是不會告訴你
小那方向出來了嗎?不會
但是我可以確定的是
哎呦
我們熟悉的慣性換邊了
我知道當下的慣性換邊了
你懂我意思嗎?
当下关心换边了
那未来呢
我不知道
但是当下符合我的要的
各位
我这边讲刻意放很慢
你听得懂吗
我不在乎那个未来
到底有没有方向
那是他家的事情
但是我在乎眼前
有没有
这个图有没有回到我的
我的惯性身上
像现在这样这么凶
例如说这根这么凶
我就会跟大家讲
后面这个不要乱吃
你至少等这根长这样子停住再说
因为这根这么凶
现在是5分K嘛
你就要多等个5分K
如果继续凶就继续等5分K
继续等等等等
然后就下去了
下去那就重来
整张图重来变成大盘整
重来重新规划边界干嘛
就会变成是这样子
所以这位问方向出来的同学
我们试试看
以后都换句话说的问
好不好
你会发现你的交易变得很轻松
你不再在乎他的方向
这才是真正的东西
有同学说
遇到来借钱的人都怎么注意
这个我讲一个真实故事
有一位
不是最近的事情
讲到借钱
前一段时间
我可能好几年了
有一位
以前学生时期就认识的学长
然后后来自己
反正大家都毕业了
做各式各樣的工作這樣
總之他就有一天打給我
他打給我的時候已經好幾個月
或是好幾可能一兩年沒有聯絡
我最近LINE看到他的打來
學弟最近過得怎麼樣啊
幹嘛幹嘛就寒暈一下
學長我最近我做了一個那個什麼鼻中隔的手術
然後他就跑來跟我講說他需要現金
因為他講一個什麼理由我忘記了
說什麼他在醫院手上沒有現金
這不是詐騙
但是因為他當時我確定是他啦
我就電話上確定是他
然後他來的時候
他說做鼻中隔的時候要缺一點現金要跟我借
那我就說這個為什麼要跟我借
他就講一下說他需要現金
立刻要支付啦blablabla
細久忘記了好重點來了
我說學長那要多少啊
20萬
然後我就跟他講學長這個我覺得真的沒有辦法
學弟這個他就開始他都不怕尷尬
那我那時候心裡想的是不對啊
他都不怕尷尬他是跟我借錢一開口借20萬弄個鼻中隔什麼的那個手術
他都不怕尷尬我在尷尬個什麼東西啊對吧
我說學長真的沒有辦法然後呢我就裝忙
啊 不好意思 我剛好忙一下 我要進電梯 拜拜 掛掉
然後我下一個動作就按封鎖
以前其實我們還有
有交集過一段時間的學長
就這樣封鎖 到現在封鎖了
好爽 好開心
但是呢 在更早之前 我們
我們還是有借一位朋友
他們買房子
投機款缺一些
一位很好的朋友
我們借給他
借給他
就是好像一个蛮有数量的金额
远远超过20万的金额
这样我们就借了
而且借的时候我们就当做没有关系
这就是我们一个好朋友
就这样帮他
所以我其实会衡量
如果那种很久没见了
把他找你借钱的
管他去死
我讲真的
你的善良不是用在这种地方
好不好
对啊别人都不要脸了
對,學長你20萬都拿不出來,沒錯
而且再來,我是他的學校的學弟再怎麼說你要建應該是先从你的家人你的兄弟姐妹你的亲戚开始吧他还是说那些都已经被借过
然后拒绝了
所以只好借到这么远
这么远的同学的学弟来
然后那个案件
就从那个之后到目前为止好像没有人跟我借钱过
可能老天爷知道找我借钱的就会被我打脸这样
没有啦我们会看人啦
那我觉得交情有差那是另外一回事
好不好
中国医药学院可以用健保700元
好来那我继续继续聊今天的内容
我這邊
所以我前面講到後來
最前面講的這些
捨不得賺捨不得賠
很大一部分是因為你
你沒有一個核心的
交易的中心思想
你不知道自己在幹嘛
所以在市場上會飄來飄去
吃到單子也不知道到底好壞
沒吃到也一直緊張
所以如果你有回頭
知道自己在幹嘛
行情要不要走出方向
像剛剛那位同學那樣子
要不要走出方向不重要
那是老天爺的事情
我在乎的是當下
小娜有沒有停住
坦白講喔
第一隻腳第二隻腳有停住
只是我現在還是找不到標準圖
因為這個圖線不對
所以如果在這裡吃
壓力在這裡支撐在這裡
現在有點尷尬
但是我會用兩條線的角度來看這件事
那现在你就等他整理
像小道琼
各位今天这样子我还蛮大胆的可以直接讲
接下来今天的后半段或是明天
如果留在这里勇敢的吃吧
这张图就会很漂亮
所以这段美股的下沙大概到这里可能差不多了
尤其是像如果留下一个日线等级尖尖的在这里
讲到这个
我前几天上礼拜吧
因为有网友问到说我可不可以看中国的股票我就看了上证然后前两天我们那天刚好看到这样子看到这个我就跟他说这个边界看到这个日线尖尖的
我说后面往这边走的几率很高
我不知道这边有没有同学有看到
有听到我讲这段话的
你看
就上去了
这不就是我们讲的吗
我没有在做中国的股票
我也没有做A50
那是很早以前的事情
但是你自己看
这不就是我们讲的尖尖的隔壁
然后同样的这种打击区的位置
当然你去做哪一支股票我不知道
我要讲的只是
这个东西是我们很熟悉很熟悉的
这样
好不好
然后呢
还有什么
来所以焦点
实际亏损之后
我们先看这个
这个是前一张
来这张
有人问说可不可以不停损
有啊
因为有些人说什么
一张不卖奇迹自来
你要看你买的点
跟你使用的金额
如果你用的金额是
无关痛痒的金额
你不要卖
OK啊
你就买
你就放着啊
但是如果你不小心
不小心买到一个
曾经的宏达电
或是曾经的威胜
或是300块的万孩
就是你懂意思吗
如果你是看着群众的情绪
买在上面的那个人
所以如果你是买那种不停损的
第一个去买大盘
买0050这种
但是你不要买在
不要买在市场在这里的时候
如果你都不打算停损
你不要买在这
你要买在下沙
并且你去看那个CNN的那个
那个fear and greed index
当他处在恐慌人那边的时候
大盘
注意哦
我不是讲个股
个股我不敢说
买大盘在这种地方
买这
然后你不停损
这种我还比较有话说
所以看你买的位置
有很大的关系
然后再来
你承受得了不停损的结果
有些人是5000万里面
拿一两千万来玩
他就算一两千万全赔掉
他还有三千万
虽然还是痛一栋房子赔掉但是他还是有三千万但是我通常这种赔掉两千万的人會立刻再撥兩千萬進來很快又賠掉兩千萬就我們這邊聽到的例子很多都是這樣子
好不好
所以這些人真的開始虧損之後
為什麼會那麼賠那麼多
因為他開始產生虧損之後很容易陷入過度交易
他滿腦子想的都是我要把剛剛的錢賺回來
我要把昨天亏的钱
上个月亏的钱
去年亏的钱
反正就是你要把亏的钱赚回来
所以你所打出来的交易
你知道我们在改作业的时候
一看就知道哪些人的交易
是报复性质的那个交易
你摆明就是想要把刚刚赔的赚回来
对不对
这样
这一看就知道那很明显
然后会进入过度交易
然后通常过度交易这个
对就像这里
又容易过度保守
因为你曾经一直赔
所以赔到后来你上师的中心思想
你不知道自己要干嘛
所以一招被蛇咬怎么样
十年怕草生
你连标准图出来的你都不敢吃
因为你怕赔
你赔太多了
赔到某个点会怕赔
那我跟你说
如果你进到这样要怎么做
第一个
先远离
物理上的远离
不是心理上的遠離我已經出來沒有
物理上面實際上面遠離盤面
遠離看盤的手機遠離看盤的電腦跟房間
出去運動去睡覺去游泳去唱歌去爬山
跟老婆去逛街都好
就是不能看盤
遠離個幾天
那個幾天我沒有辦法告訴你
每個人都不太一樣
遠離的第一天很難熬
因為你會覺得好想看盤
今天不知道怎么喷出
远离的第二天
那个感觉就会淡化一些些
远离的第三天
好像三天没下单
日子照过
猫照跑狗照跳
好像可以
那个感觉会降一些
这个时候你再回来
真的打开行情
你才会觉得说
我好像慢慢心情会
你就不會再追在那個行情裡面了
所以通常大概需要幾天的時間
然後這幾天的時間回來以後要幹嘛
要放在
你的交易计划你的标准动作
你的焦点要摆在那个地方
但是你要先有远离才有这个
你说不行我很快就可以拉回来
我觉得三分钟我就拉回来了
然后我可以继续做
你的圣诞树就是这样来的不是吗
你大赔就是你以为你三分钟就可以冷却不是吗
我跟各位说我是人
你也是人
所以我们要冷却的不是三分钟
是天
你就慢慢的让它过去
我同学说上手真的很有用
对,我们需要这样子
然后这时候假设你已经远离了
第四天回来
回来以后你要对着自己讲话
你去照着镜子跟自己讲话一下
说对着他讲
老于,你从现在开始是个很棒的推的
成功的推的
所以你从现在开始的每一步
你都会照着该有的交易步骤
该有的顺序来做交易
好上工开始做交易
然后一坐下
哎呀一个成功的推折会怎么想呢
好他会这样这样这样
对吧
你就开始去演那个角色
演那个好的交易计划
好的标准动作的角色
这样知道那种感觉
这些动作是我亲身做过
真的很有用的动作
而且我也帮助很多同学
去把圣诞书
把整个情绪给拉出来
都蛮有用的
但是这个步骤需要你自己做
我顶多只能告诉你怎么做
你还是需要自己去冷却
好不好
还有什么
Trader
我认真讲话
发音标准一点
看一下Google
可以啊
Google
继续杀了
没有用
Google
Google可以
我在我的公司户那边
我有吃Google
Google可以
我就是抓這個邊界,這附近,只要來了這邊,我都會吃5k87%拉回真的吗真的吗真的吗真的吗
小那对不对
5k有5k又一次来
一个点两个点破有没有
刚刚在前面的1k这里在这里面的1k刚刚不是有吗
就是一个点两个点破对吧
大家不用急不用急
就算在1k你都有东西吃不用急
他刚回来而已你等这个等这个等这个
今天这样子停住我觉得后面很棒
后面很棒
今天的60k
今天的60k你要等
我以现在而言要等久的
因为眼前的60k还在往这边走
所以你至少等个60k
例如说你看一下前面
我在这边这段我有做交易
我忘记吃在哪里了
你回去看这附近的交易
这是附近的单子
我做的交易是长线短线都有的
你看一下这个60k
下来整理出一个这样子
这个就很美
现在是下来都还没有开始整理
你先等他整理一下再说
这样
好不好
我们看一下同学要问的一些股票
10点
我等一下准备下课了
只有6237成本33.4
6237是什么
这个
成本33.4
是不是回到加码的附近
这个
如果你当初吃在这边
如果你当初吃在这里
对不对
我在猜你应该是吃这附近
这个破底翻可以
但是现在
现在不要再用破底翻来看了
已经不一样了
现在请你用两条线来看
而且来套用我们刚刚所学的
K棒凶不凶
在我的萤幕下沙是红色
所以空方力量是从最高价到收盘价
这根的空方力量是满满满的
这样子
所以是这样子
好不好
所以这个如果我是你你当初的防守在哪里你就守原来的地方可能明天破你就直接出
因为眼前的样子
如果你要重新进来
你例如说假设你明天破的时候出
但是尾盘收回来长这样子
你宁愿等收回来的这时候
再重新的建立你新的部位
都不迟这样
2601然后下一个A XTI可以
2601买在6.5
买在6.5
明天如果下来出一半年一半继续读
所以你是今天买在这的吗
今天买在刚开盘这时候吧
坦白说你的买法不像是我平常的买法
所以我不敢说这个买法好或坏
反正結果論就漲上去的嘛
那
明天如果有下來出一半
另外一半繼續賭
不是上去才要出嗎
還是你的意思是什麼
如果有下來回到成本出一半
另外一半繼續往下凹
如果跌都沒關係
是這樣子的嗎
這樣不行哦
好不好
我的建議是
如果明天回到6.5
直接全部出場,重來
前幾天買在6.5
前幾天如果你買在6.5
那為什麼這邊沒有走
你的防守,對吧
你的防守是6嗎
因為你的買法不是我平常常見的買法
所以我沒有辦法
給你一個好的什麼建議
但是我可以看到的是
你的進出不太對
我不知道能怎麼幫你挑
但是眼前看到的是
我们应该是喷出的时候走
例如说假设我买在这里
喷出来老鱼我在这里走一半
另外一半继续赌成本在底下
这样OK
如果是这样子我完全可以过
而不是买在中间
然后用这样子去熬
也不是买在喷出的时候
然后守这个
这样子不对
所以我的建议是你可能要先回去把我在新手避看专区里面就我们的交易法的逻辑因为这边很多同学其实都已经会了那你还不会没有关系
我会建议你花一点时间去把那一段看完
那些看完你会很有底
知道怎么防守怎么什么的
这样
我今天
虽然我是在念你
但其实我是真的是为你好
我才想说
你这些单子回到成本赶快先走
然后把那些看完
这样
好不好
好,来还有什么呢
AXTI
这什么股票
你要问我什么呢
在哪里
是否回
回踩可以加吗
这个吧
不行啦
怎么会加码在喷出的时候呢
你加码在喷出的时候
你的均价是不是快速的电高
我们是加码在哪里
假设哪一天有回来到这里
加码在这种地方
或是干脆喷上去
回来有高有低的才是我们的加码
有高有低才是加码
你看一下当初一定有人加码在90
但刚加完然后就掉下来掉到70
那这些在这边找到边界慢慢加码的人
他是不是直接省了这20块钱
对吗
这样子
好不好
所以这边如果有回踩
不会哦
我不会加码在
在大科度都撞墙的附近
我觉得对军价的上升
不怎么有利
有人说我是亚洲父母
对啊
我是亚洲父母啊
我将是为你好
9904怎么样
9904成本在23
是不是又回到
如果要加碼
对不对
像这种的加碼才是好的
看得懂吗
同样的家嘛
不是喷出的家
是回来到边界的家
这种家比起喷出的家
漂亮太多了
刚好这两只可以当做对比
这样子
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:20:00 起〕